돼지 평단가로 봤을 때는 거의 한
3억, 3천, 3억, 4천 뭐이 정도
수준이에요. 그래서 굉장히 높은
상태고 그냥 내놓은 거예요, 여러분.
내 놓은 건데이 기사들 막 보면은
진짜 판 것처럼 어 350억에 판
것처럼 이렇게 기사가 나는데 그래서
제가 진짜 뭐 낱낱이 이렇게 소개를
하고 싶지만 유튜브에서 말씀을 못
드려요.
그래서 이번 주도 제가 뉴스를 좀
준비를 했습니다. 그래서 첫 번째
뉴스부터 좀 보면은 어 매년 부실이
배로 늘어 공실 속출 임대업에 뜬
대출 경고등이라는 기사예요. 그래서
9월 7일 날 나온 건데 어 부동산
임대역 공실이 많이 늘어나서 연체율이
되게 높아졌다라고 합니다. 그래서
실제로 지금 이런 부분 때문에 최근에
은행에서도 대출을 되게 깐깐하게 보기
시작했어요. 그 전까지만 해도 신규
법인 같은 경우에는 뭐 부동산
임대업이어도 대출이 좀 잘 나왔는데
어 요즘에는 대출 제한이 좀
많아졌습니다. 그래서 RTI도
적용되고요. 원래는 법인 같은
경우에가 적용이 안 됐는데 최근에는
RTI 적용을 좀 받고 있습니다.
그래서 뭐 이런 부분 때문에 은행들이
되게 좀 보수적으로 보는 거 같아요.
실제로 지금 임대 상황이 좀 좋지
않아서 어 연체율이 높아지고 있는 거
같습니다. 두 번째 기사 같은
경우에는 어 7월 서울 오피스 시장
거래 금액 반토막 공실은 4%에
6박한다라는 기사인데 일단 보셔야
될게 서울 오피스 거래량이라고 하는데
이게 보시면은 프라임급 빌딩이에요.
그래서 굉장히 규모가 큰 빌딩이고
그게 이제 6월 달이 12건이 됐는데
7월 달이 이제 여섯 건으로
줄어들어서 뭐 반토망이 났다라는
기사입니다. 근데 5월 달에는네
건밖에 없었어요. 그래서 이렇게 뭔가
그냥 헤드라인을 좀 자극적으로 이렇게
뺀 거 같고 사실 프라인급 빌딩들은
거래가 좀 잘 안 돼요. 네. 그래서
그거 감안해서 보시면 될 거 같고
우리가 찾는 그런 작은 규묘의 빌딩은
참고할 만한 데이터는 좀 아닌 거
같습니다. 근데 여기 기사에서 그래도
좀 유심히 봐야 될 거는 이런
프라임급 빌딩들도 공실이 조금
높아지고 있다. 뭐 이런 부분은
참고해서 보면 좋을 거 같아요. 원래
프라임급 빌딩들이 공실이 낮거든요.
어 최근에 그래도 조금 높아지고
있다. 뭐이 부분은 참고해도 좋을 것
같습니다. 그리고 가수 퇴지나 12년
만에 매각한 이태원 빌딩 뭐 위치
시세 차익 대박 뭐 이렇게 해가지고
헤드라인을 뺐는데 근데 저는
개인적으로 이게 지금 돼지가
100평이 좀 넘거든요. 그래서 지금
300뭐 50억의 매물로 내놨다 이런
기사가 있는데 대지 평단가로 봤을
때는 거의 한 3억 3천 3억 4천
뭐이 정도 수준이에요. 그래서 굉장히
높은 상태고 그냥 내놓은 거예요
여러분. 내놓은 건데이 기사들 막
보면은 진짜 판 것처럼 어 350억에
판 것처럼 이렇게 기사가 났는데 보통
이런 기사들이 어떻게 나냐면 부동산
업체에서 본인 회사 업체를 좀
홍보하기 위해서 이렇게 좀 자극적으로
기자분들한테 많이 이렇게 제보를
해요. 뭐 지금 시세가 어느 정도
된다라고 해서 뭐 100억 벌었다
200억 벌었다 뭐 그렇게 기사가
많이 나가는데 한 10년 전 20년
전 샀던 거는 당연히 그때 당시엔
싸게 샀죠. 여러분들이 너무 그런데
현혹되지 마시고 실패 사례도 되게
많습니다. 그래서 제가 진짜 뭐
낱낱이 이렇게 소개를 하고 싶지만
유튜브에서 말씀을 못 드려요. 저
예전에 그 기사 냈다가 그 모
연예인분 매니저한테 계속 전화
와가지고 진짜 엄청 시달렸습니다.
진짜 연예인분들 빌딩 실패 사례도
되게 많은데 어 대부분 이제 연예인
빌딩 보면 이렇게 자극적인 기사가
많은 거 같아요. 그래서 지금
태진하시 건물 같은 경우에는 그
파크사이드 서울 같이 붙어 있어요.
파크사이드 서울이 이제 개발되면은 좀
좋아질 거다라는 뭐 얘기 때문에 거기
인근의 부동산 가격이 많이 좀 이렇게
효과가 높아지긴 했는데 저는
개인적으로 모르겠습니다. 과연
350억에 팔릴지 한번 좀 지켜보면
좋을 거 같아요. 그리고 또 보면은
어 윤민수 40억의 상암동 건물을
샀는데 지금 45억 원에 내놨다라는
기사가 많습니다. 그 이때가 어느
때였냐면 금리 딱 올리기 전이에요.
정말 매파적으로 금리 엄청 올릴
거다라고 발언을 하고 설마 저렇게까지
하겠어라고 했던 때예요. 그때 22년
6월 이후로 금리가 아주 가파르게
올랐습니다. 그래서 이때까지만 해도
그래도 빌딩 거래량도 많고 가격도
되게 높았었어요. 근데 이제 딱
막바지에 사 가지고 지금 사실 거의
한 3년 넘었는데 45억에 내놓은
거면 거의 남는게 없습니다. 그래서
거의 원가 수준에 내놓은 거고 근데
여기서 좀 보셔야 될 거는 그 법인
공동명이로 샀어요. 근데 이제 지부은
유민수 씨 법인이 더 많아요.
아무래도 연예인분들은 상함동이
익숙하고 그리고 이제 실사용 목적도
있다 보니까 그쪽으로 많이 매입하는
거 같은데 좀 개인적으로 본질이 되게
중요한 거 같습니다. 빌딩은 정말
그냥 투자 가치로 봐야 되는 부분이
있는 거 같고 그런 부분은 좀 아쉬운
거 같습니다. 그리고 마지막으로 어
이건이 회장님 집을 228억에 현금
주고 산 어 84년생 여성이
누구냐라는 기사들이 굉장히 많이
나왔는데 제가 조금 살펴봤어요. 네.
살펴봤는데 어 태화 홀딩스라는
회사인데 직원이 일곱명인데 작년
매출이 4,55억이에요.
진짜 알짜요? 어 지금 명인데 어
4,55억이면
진짜 엄청난 거거든요. 그리고 작년
영업 이익이 한 111억 정도 되는
거 같습니다. 22년도에는 한
2,700억 정도 하다가
2023년도에는 3,300억. 그다음
2024년도에는 4,억이 넘었어요.
되게 알짜 회사인 거 같습니다. 전에
이제 이건희 회장님이 2010년도에
82억 원을 샀습니다. 이번에
228억에 어 매각한 그런 사례라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. 그래서
자녀들이랑 살기에는 어 정말 너무
좋은 거 같습니다. 그리고 이건희
회장님이 얼마나 털를 보셨겠어요.
터가 굉장히 좀 좋은 곳이지 않나?
네. 그렇게 예상을 합니다. 네.
그래서 제가 뉴스 브리핑을 좀 했는데
어 다음 시간에도 제가 알차게 뉴스를
준비해서 어 또 촬영해 보도록
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]